ce sont des accusations graves Cécile
Duflou vous avez écouté cette émission
les propos de François Fillon qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à cela je crois que ce
sont pas des des accusations je pense
que c'est une combine une méthode
c'est-à-dire que vous voyez que François
Fillon se est dans une NAS ù
effectivement semaine après semaine on
révèle qu'il est le contraire de ce
qu'il avait fait croire c'est-à-dire un
homme honnête engagé pour l'intérêt
général comme il est coincé il invente
un peu façon Trump ou façon d'autrre un
une énormité encore plus grosse et comme
ça regardez la
exaement c'est la fameuse formule de pas
si vous êtes pris dans une affaire
invente une affaire dans l'affaire puis
uneaire dans l'affaire dans l'affaire à
la fin les gens seront perdus compr
diversion aussi oui c'est c'est plus que
diversion c'est de la combine c'est ce
que c'est de la manipulation c'est de la
manipulation la la meilleure preuve
c'est qu'on en parle ce matin c'estàdire
qu'on on se dit pas est-ce que c'est
normal qu'un candidat à la l'élection
présidentielle dans notre pays soit sous
le coup d'une mise en examen pour abus
de bien social escroquerie
aggravé manquem l'obligation
h imaginez l'énormité quand même comme
le Parti socialiste cette semaine vous
demandez à ce que le candidat Fillon se
retire moi je pense qu'il aurait déjà dû
se retirer mais on voit bien que la
situation est là où il est d'une
mauvaise foi ultime moi je suis pas dans
les petits papiers d'Alain Jupé mais
quand il dit si Alain Jupé avait été
candidat peut-être que j'aurais pu il
men de façon hantée et je pense que
c'est le problème principal qu'on a avec
François Fillon c'est qu'il a une espèce
de capacité au mensonge serein qui et
oui ben bien sûr bien sûr